مع اكثر من ثلاثه فاصل لسته مليارات
مستخدم حول العالم اصبحت وسائل التواصل
وسيله قويه لمشاركه الافكار مع الاخرين
لكنها ايضا اصبحت مصدر توتر وقلق بالنسبه
للملايين خصوصا لدى المراهقين وفقا لمركز
بيول للابحاث فان 81% من المراهقين في
الولايات المتحده يستخدمون وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الابحاث تؤكد ان واحدا من كل
سته مراهقين يتعرضون لاشكال من السلوك
المسيء عبر الانترنت كذلك فان المعهد
الوطني للصحه العقليه في الولايات المتحده
يؤكد ان نحو 22% من المراهقين سيعانون من
ضعف عقلي حاد في حياتهم بسبب هذه الوسائل
فيما يؤكد استطلاع ان تسعه بالمئه من كل
عشره مراهقين يؤكدون ان التحرش عبر
الانترنت يمثل مشكله للاشخاص في سنهم فيما
يفيد نحو 24% من المراهقين انهم يعتقدون
ان وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لها تاثير
سلبي بشكل عام عليهم
[موسيقى]